بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والعاقبه للمتقين ولا عدوان الا
على الظالمين والصلاه والسلام على سيد
المرسلين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين ومن سار على نهجهم واتبع سنتهم
واقتفى اثرهم الى يوم الدين اما بعد
ولينصرن الله من ينصره ان الله قوي عزيز
ابناء شعبنا الفلسطيني
المرابط شعب المقاومه في غزه الشامخه
امتنا العربيه والاسلاميه يا احرار
العالم في اليوم الثام
ث للعدوان الصهيوني على قطاعنا
الحبيب لا يزال شعبنا
الفلسطيني في غزه الابيه يضرب اروع
الامثله في الثبات والصمود والتح حدي وهو
يقدم نماذج اعجزت العالم
وجعلته يقف احتراما
واجلالا امام هذا العطاء والاستعداد
للتضحيه رغم ما يواجهه من اهوال وجرائم
يندى لها جبين
الانسانيه يقوم بها هذا العدو الذي استباح
كل شيء بمنتهى
الهمجيه
والوحشيه ان هذا الشعب العظيم يستحق اسمى
ايات التحيه والتقدير
والاحترام فقد اثبت رغم الوجع الكبير الذي
يعيشه من الم النزوح والتدمير
والمجازر التي تعرض وما زال لها بانه شعب
راسخ العقيده متش بع بالايمان متمرس على
المقاومه
والصمود تربى على الثقه بالله والتوكل
عليه واليقين بحتم
الانتصار مع الاعداد والمرابط والمصابره
والاحتساب
انه شعب يليق به شرف الانتماء لهذه الارض
المباركه والحفاظ عليها وحمايه
مقدساتها
وكذلك شعبنا في القدس
والضفه رغم التنكيل والقمع
والارهاب والاقتحامات والاعدامات
والاعتقالات
التعسفيه وعربده المستوطنين وتقطيع
الاوصال الا انه سيبقى عصيا
شامخا متجددا في
مقاومته واجياله محتفظه بحقها في المواجهه
الموحده
والشامله مع اخوانهم في غزه وفي كل
مكان ونحن نؤمن بان اراده الله
غالبه وجبروت الاحتلال زائل وفلسطين وغزه
شاهد على الغزاه الذين تعاقبوا على هذه
الارض فذهبوا
واندثر وبقيت غزه شامخه وبقي اهلها ثابتون
في ارضهم لا يضرهم من خالفهم ولا من خذلهم
الا ما اصابهم من
لاواء 88 يوما والمقاومه مستب سله في
الميدان تسقط اهداف العدو الموهومه واحدا
تلو الاخر وخاصه في مراحل العدوان الاولى
والثانيه التي اراد فيها تفكيك وتدمير
المقاومه وتهجير شعبنا واستعاده جنوده
الاسرى غير ان المقاومه ما زالت بفضل الله
في تصاعد
متواصل تذيق هذا العدو وجيشه جزاء جرائمهم
فالمقاومة راح اسرى العدو الا بشروط
المقاومه سيده المكان والزمان في غزه
وفلسطين ان هذه العمليات البطوليه
الاستثنائيه التي نراها وشعبنا وامتنا هي
غيض من
فيض مما تقوم به المقاومه كل يوم
وساعه وتؤكد ان هؤلاء الابطال يستبسل
لدفع حياتهم ثمنا لحريه شعبهم
ووطنهم وكل يوم يمر يزيد من مقاومتنا قوه
وصلابه وثقه
بالنصر كيف لا والمجاهدون حينما يرمون
يصدحون بقوله سبحانه وما رميت اذ رميت
ولكن الله رمى
وشاهدت الامه جمعاء الشهيد الرباني الذي
صعدت روحه وهو ساجد مقبل غير مدبر نحسبه
والله حسيبه ممن اصطفاهم الله تعالى و
ووفقهم لحسن الخاتمه حافظ للقران امام
للمصلين وخير الختام ما كان شهاده وسجودا
وهذه هي طبيعه هذا الصف بل الشعب المؤمن
المجاهد الذي قال الله فيه عبادا لنا
الولي باس
شديد لقد جعلتم ايها الابطال دبابات
الاحتلال وناقلات توابيت متفحمه واستطعت
ان تقه على اعتاب احياء غزه واصبحتم امام
العالم
اساير يتنى بها وهم يشاهدون بوت
الفذه بل ان قاده دول ومسؤولين في جيوش
يعيدون مشاهده صور ابداعاتكم
مذهولين
معتزين وانتم تواجهون الجي الذي كان لا
يقهر وتحي المعاني العظيمه في هذه الامه
وانا من هنا اطمئن شعبنا
وامتنا ان المجاهدين وقياداتهم بخير
ويمارسون مهامهم القياديه بكل جداره
واقتدار فخورون بشعب وامت وبكل احرار
العالم الذين وقفوا مع الحق
الفلسطيني والتحيه الى الاعلام العسكري
للقسام
ولفائف الذي ابدع في الميدان بجان
بالمقاتلين ينقل صوره البطولات الى جماهير
الامه العربيه والاسلاميه والعالم كله
ويظهر جبن الجندي الصهيوني وهزيمته امام
الرجال ولقد مثلت هذه المشاهد الركيزه
الاساسيه
للانتصار في معركه الوعي حيث اراد
الاحتلال من هذه المعركه بث روح الهزيمه
والانكسار لدى عموم
شعبنا
وخاصه اهلنا هناك في غزه فانقلب السحر على
الساحر وظهر كذب الاحتلال وانكشف وجهه
القبيح واسقط مجاهدو وجهود الاعلام
العسكري ومعنا كل الاعلام الحر المعادله
الظالمه التي ارادها الاحتلال
واصبحت الامه تتغنى بجهاد غزه
ومقاومتها
وبطولاتها وثبات وصبر حاضنتها الشعبيه
العظيمه
المباركه يا ابناء
شعبنا لقد بدا الاحتلال يروج بانه ينتقل
من المرحله الثانيه الى الثالثه للقيام
بعمليات عسكريه
مركزه لمنع المقاومه من
النهوض
ولكنها ستسقط على يد المقاومه كما سقطت
سابقاتها
فابطله المقاومه يصنعون اليوم تاريخا
وعهدا جديدا
لفلسطين فلسطين حره عزيزه كريمه
ويؤكدون فعلا وقولا ان اليوم والغد هو
لشعبنا
وتنا ونحن من
يقرر نحن من يقرر
لانفسنا
وحاضرنا
ومستقبلنا شعبنا الفلسطيني الابي الصامد
امتنا العظيمه احرار
العالم ان هذا العدوان
سيتوقف تحت ضربات المقاومه وصمود
شعبنا وليس امام الاحتلال الا الاستجابه
لاراده
شعبنا واود ان اشير
هنا الى انه وفي ضوء المبادرات
والعروض التي وصلت الى قياده الحركه عبر
الاخوه في مصر
وقطر وبعد دراسه هذه الافكار بايجابيه
فقد قدمت الحركه لقطر
ومصر موقفها
ورؤيتها الذي ترتكز فيه على الوقف الشامل
للعدوان على شعبنا
واغاثه
والاستجابه لمطالبه المحق
والعاد واود ان اشير
ايضا الى ان الحركه تلقت العديد من
مبادرات تتعلق بالوضع الفلسطيني
الداخلي صادره عن جهات
وشخصيات فلسطينيه
وعربيه حريصه على شعبنا وقضيتنا
ووحدتنا وقد اكدنا للجميع تمسك الحركه
بوحده الشعب
والقضيه وهي منفتحه على كافه المكونات
الوطنيه من اجل اعاده بناء المرجعيه
الوطنيه في اطار المنظمه عبر الخيار
الديمقراطي الى جانب الاتفاق على حكومه
وطنيه للضفه
والقطاع والعمل على اساس برنامج المقاومه
والثوابت وفي مقدمتها الدوله وعاصمتها
القدس وحق العوده وتقرير
المصير والى ان يتم انجاز
ذلك فانه لن يكون هناك فوضى او فراغ في
القطاع فالا جزه الشرطيه
والامنيه تعمل حاليا والمؤسسات
الحكوميه وخاصه الاطقم الطبيه والدفاع
المدني تقوم بجهدها بالامكانات المتاحه في
ظل الحرب
والعدوان يا اهلنا الصامدين في
غزه اننا ندرك ان الايام الحاليه مؤلمه
وثقيله ولكنها سوف تمضي ويمضي معها
الطغيان وسيعود شعبنا باذن الله الى بيوته
التي نزح منها وسنعمل يدا بيد لاعاده بناء
ما دمره الاحتلال
والعدوان ونحن نعمل على مضار
الساعه مع الجميع من اجل ان يحصل شعبنا
على
احتياجاته وينعم بالحريه
والاستقلال وفي الوقت
ذاته اذ نحمل الاحتلال المسؤوليه الكامله
عن هذه
المعاناه فان الدول التي شاركت وساندت هذا
العدوان وخاصه الاداره
الامريكيه تتح حمل المسؤوليه
الكامله من حيث دعمها العسكري والامني
والسياسي لدوله
الاحتلال والوقوف في وجه اراده المجتمع
الدولي الذي ينادي بوقف العدوان وانصاف
شعبنا يا شعبنا البطل يا امتنا
المجاهده لقد وضعت هذه الحرب شعبنا
وقضيتنا في محطه
جديده
مختلفه يدرك فيها العالم اجمع الا امن ولا
استقرار ولا مستقبل في المنطقه الا بحصول
شعبنا على حريته وحقوقه المشروعه في ارضه
ووطنه واقامه دولته المستقله وعاصمتها
القدس وانجاز حق
العوده و لا مستقبل للاحتلال على
ارضنا بل لا شرعيه للاحتلال على شبر من
ارض
فلسطين كما اكدت هذه
الحرب ان شعبنا ليس
وحيدا بل معه امتنا العربيه
والاسلاميه والكثير الكثير من الاحرار في
العالم شرقا
وغربا ان معركه غزه تضا
على مستوى
العالم
وهنا نوجه التحيه لكل المشاركين في اسناد
هذه المعركه العظيمه على امتداد الوطن
العربي
والاسلامي والتحيه والاعتزاز
للشهداء الذين قضوا في اسناد المعركه
عسكريا في لبنان واليمن
والعراق وان مشاهده الملايين في مدن وعوا
شرق الارض
وغربها تخرج لترفع صوتها عاليا ضد العدوان
الغاشم ونصره ونصره لشعبنا وادانه الكيان
الصهيوني
وجرائمه البشعه ضد الانسانيه ليؤكد ان
العالم يدرك ان الاحتلال يمثل كل الشرور
وانه ان الاوان للح حكومات الاستجابه الى
الحق والضمير والمعاني
الانسانيه التي نصت عليها القوانين
والقرارات الدوليه وان تتخلى عن صمتها على
الانحياز الامريكي الغربي للاحتلال
وتعاملها
بازدواجيه المعايير فيما يتعلق بفلسطين
وقضيتها وحقوق شعبنا
واحيي مجددا كل المواقف الداعمه
والمسانده واخص هنا دوله جنوب
افريقيا التي توجهت بشكوى الى محكمه العدل
الدوليه ضد دوله الاحتلال بسبب جرائمها ضد
الانسانيه والتطهير العرقي والاباده
الجماعيه ونحن نقدر الاهميه السياسيه
والقانونيه لهذه الدعوه ولهذه
الشكوى والتي ترسخ ان القضيه الفلسطينيه
وغزه هي قضيه انسانيه سياسيه
عادله ونتطلع كشعب عانى
ويعاني من احتلال عنصري لاكثر من 75 عام
ان يصدر قرار يحقق العدل لشعبنا وقضيته
ويوقف جرائم الحرب التي تجري اليوم
في غزه الابيه شعبنا
العظيم في مطلع العام
الميلادي
اخاطبكم وكلي يقين ان هذا العام سيكون
عاما ملؤه العزه والكرامه وسيفتح اجنده
النصر والتحرير باذن الله وكذلك سيفتح
مسيره الانهيار
والزوال للاحتلال الفاشي غاصب ولن يكون له
مكان على ارضنا وفي قدسنا وهو عام تحرير
اسرانا بحول الله وقوته وهو عام تجسيد
وحده شعبنا في الداخل
والخارج في
الختام لقد قلنا ونقول
ونكرر لا امن ولا استقرار في منطقه الا
بزوال
الاحتلال قلنا
ونكرر لن تمر مؤامره
التهجير قلنا ونكرر لا عوده عن المطالبه
بتحرير كافه
الاسرى
قلنا
ونكرر
وليفهم من لا يفهم اي ترتيبات في القضيه
الفلسطينيه
دون حركه حماس وفصائل المقاومه وهم
وسراب والله غالب على امره ولكن اكثر
الناس لا يعلمون وانه لجهاد نصر او
استشهاد والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته